des mots comme cela remet de la
détermination communique munitions
depuis que son fils des miennes est mort
il ya plus de nom en combattant avec un
groupe extrémiste en syrie christian
boudreau fait tout pour éviter que
d'autres jeunes suivent son chemin cela
fait des mois qu'elle multiplie les
rencontres au canada et ailleurs dans le
monde
elle discute avec des experts et des
parents d'autres jeunes à qui la
radicalisation a coûté la vie avaient
été des enfants et les jeunes d'y aller
avec des maires originaires de sept pays
occidentaux musulmane et non musulmanes
c'est cette lettre qu'elle publie
maintenant sur les réseaux sociaux
terrain propice au recrutement
djihadiste
une manière donc de combattre le feu par
le feu le texte est riche en références
religieuses au on va prouver les propres
messages qui socrates qui sont vraiment
là pour faire les questions d'anne
orthez pau demander si c'est vrai ou pas
le texte souligne que le coran demande
aux croyants de faire preuve de bonté
envers ses parents les auteurs de la
lettre affirme qu'avec la radicalisation
et le départ de leurs enfants on leur a
pris ce qu'elles avaient de plus cher à
winnipeg la présidente de l'association
des services sociaux islam et kaki des
les auteurs de la lettre dans les
références religieuses
elle estime que l'outil peut aider à
guider certains jeunes tentés par la
radicalisation
elle croit aussi que c'est une façon
pour les maires de mettre un baume sur
leur douleur
il faut dire que depuis la mort de son
fils christian boudreau s'est sentis
abandonnés par les autorités pour
plusieurs réseaux ce pour faire des
préparations d'éducation travail avec
les jeunes dans ce club
n'importe quoi aucun des bombes
benneteau doigt des revendications pour
plus de prévention qui se feront
entendre bien longtemps parce que comme
l'indiquent la lettre christian boudreau
et les autres maires n'ont pas
l'intention de se taire ici rafale
bouvier oakley radio-canada et